hi my name is Alvin and today I'll be
teaching you how to make my prime rib
with garlic butter so prime rib is
commonly eaten around the holidays and I
love prime rib I love steak steak is my
number one favorite thing to eat and to
make in the entire world if you don't
know what prime rib is it is essentially
just a bunch of rib eyes stacked
together it is what rib eyes would be if
you did not cut steaks from them and for
the seasoning this is just a very
seasoned garlic butter with a lot of
spices it's just gonna help the prime
rib get a lot of flavor and it's gonna
taste really awesome garlic and butter
go really well with the steak so why not
just have it one prime rib and this
method you're kind of coating the whole
thing I know it's a lot of butter but
it's gonna help flavor this huge piece
of meat it's gonna melt off we're gonna
use that later so don't worry about it
and it's the holidays you're not trying
to diet I hope not you are maybe don't
watch this video because it's a lot of
butter
this technique is actually very
interesting I was actually trying it for
the first time this is like the 500
degree technique where you put it in the
oven super super hot 500 degrees for
around 30 minutes depending on the
weight and size of your roast and then
you do this technique where you just you
turn the oven off but you'll leave the
door closed and you do not open it
because the residual heat is supposed to
continue to cook the prime rib all the
way through it's gonna smell great it's
gonna look great
cannot open the door if you open the
oven door he's just gonna come out just
gonna have a raw prime rib and that's no
good if your oven has a fan that helps
to take away that heat this method will
not work it's just gonna end up raw so
double-check that your fan doesn't try
to carry away that extra heat or also
you need to look up some other cooking
methods for the pan break I cook it to
medium rare you cook it ever you like
just emphasize medium-rare probably
can't be my friend you take it out after
that two hours or two and a half hours
let it rest and while that kind of you
know happens on the side we want to make
a gravy because prime rib is essentially
cooked as a whole roast it's actually
not gonna get super seasoned all the way
through so when you slice it you
actually need to make sure that you have
some sort of seasoning or sauce this
case we're gonna make a gravy what you
can do
you can use the drippings from the pan
that you made the Prime ribbon which was
the beef fat all that butter all those
flavors all those juices that garlic
still in there don't waste it
so you're gonna want to strain out take
out any of the super burnt bits leave
behind the fat and the juices combined
that you know with some flour with some
beef stock and some other things and
kind of cook it over heat until it gets
nice and thickened to a sauce so that's
gonna be the gravy for the prime rib
it's pretty awesome and you can season
as you go
when I was making this video actually it
was pretty late I think it was like even
a weekend where it was just the super
expensive huge chunk of ribeye and I
really did not want to mess it up and I
was very scared I was gonna you know
make it you don't mess it up and have to
spend more money to get it right and it
is an expensive cut so make sure that
you do treat it well if you have a meat
thermometer that'll save you a lot of
headache into knowing if it's cooked or
not you want to aim for around 130 to
135 if you're going for medium-rare
anything higher than that is just more
well-done and my favorite part is just
really just it's that reveal so when you
first get that nice thick slice out of
there and the whole thing just comes out
it's juicy it's pink it's perfectly
cooked you play it with some nice mashed
potatoes you played it with some nice
vegetables you support some gravy you
kind of drench it in gravy for me and
that's pretty much it you kind of go ham
you go in and you try not to get a
second slice but knowing me I'm gonna
get like three slices you're not gonna
eat it only at Christmas you're gonna
want an excuse to make it any time of
the year you get prime rib make sure you
go to a good butcher depending on how
many people you have you might need to
ask for a four bone roast a six bone
roast and a bone roast ten depending on
how big your dinner party is and how
hungry
you think everybody's gonna be and you
want to make sure that you look for
prime rib but the most deckle or the
most capped because the cap is the
tastiest part on a ribeye it's delicious
and you kind of want as big of that
muscle as possible so if you're having
guests over it's a huge way to sort of
entertain them impress them because when
you serve up prime rib there's a whole
Teatre Calla tea bring it out to the
table
cutting huge slice of serving everybody
so yeah if you do make a let me know
send over pictures ask me questions it's
you know one of my favorite recipes of
all time we've ever made
taystee one of the proudest I've ever
been happy to help you guys out and I
just want you guys to enjoy your steak
as much as I do
[Music]